what's up everybody you're probably
wondering if this is going to be a
stupid video or an actual video where i
talk about things and um
yeah i'm going to talk about my my
bookshelf
[Music]
i don't have much of an order sanderson
here mistborn i don't have the third
miss born but
that's uh that's
i don't know got children of dune
and some jack london i really love these
editions of the lord of the rings i just
think they look really nice
gardens of the moon all ready to be read
soon
james joyce uh john steinbeck
one of the original publications of this
book
and this is probably my prized because
it is signed
by none other than uh
i don't know who that is but science
fiction over here some more arthur c
clark some poetry i love these library
of america editions because you get
so much in them then we just got some
stacks you know haven't read all of
these
got stephen king stack got an old copy
of it
never seen that book before in my life
samuel delaney nova don quixote
really nice version of war and peace oh
these are cool these are my
i think these are my great grandfathers
faulkner over here sounding the fury the
reavers
various other stuff
i have the dark tower here because this
is what i've read this is what i
have yet to read although i'm almost
done with that washington dc guidebook
[Music]
kafka from hemingway school books we've
had to read
down below let's see some more chaos
and some of my favorite uh children's
books that i bothered to keep
that's uh that's one of the bookshelves
anyways got uh oh yeah short stories i
like to keep short stories together
and then here's the the bulk of the
poetry down here
one of my favorites right here
gravity's rainbow who knows if i'll ever
read that
and what why is this why do we have this
out
it's like not christmas anymore
when we run out of space we just go to
the kitchen because we have way more
books than we do have kitchen supplies
also the movies are
in this case
oh that about does it folks
it's